our next review comes from going to
guides who writes you are a joy and a
delight just listen to the latest
episode where you ponder products to
endorse like clooney and his tequila a
wine cooler or rose wine was mentioned
what if you created a fizzy wine cooler
that was not rose pink but conan
pompadour orange i for one would buy it
by the case anywho i love you conan and
i get so happy when i see there's a new
podcast episode to listen to let me know
when the coco zay is ready to buy xoxo
shannon
i wish she had said xoxo girl
shannon you know who would love this is
my manager
gavin pallone constantly
begging me why aren't i doing some kind
of big product integration yeah that's
going to make him a billionaire and you
know and he really was fascinated with
clooney clooney has this tequila you
know he and randy gerber they sold the
company for a billion dollars and i
think right that's george clooney
nobody like that's a very very handsome
movie star and people want to emulate
what he's doing
there's not a goddamn person in america
who's like how do i capture that conan
magic with the ladies santa shannon no
shannon that's very nice of you but
i swear to god no one
when they saddle up to the bar says what
does conan o'brien drink that's the
drink for me
or what's he wearing i've got to wear a
conan o'brien suit that says this is a
man who means business
now fizzy wine cooler probably kind of
works yeah it does
so an orange and and she had a pitch for
the coco what
i like that i said pompadour i like coco
but i just i honestly don't see and this
is not me being hard on myself this is
me being completely honest i don't see
anyone
linking me
to
a product
that's meant for socializing
having drinks you know what i mean i
don't know who's gonna say let's get a
coke jose seriously i think it's to be
funny i think people will do it not to
be like cool but to be funny like hey
i'll have a coke jose and orange drink
fizzy drink shows up like that's funny
i don't know that people buy liquor
because it's funny yeah maybe not i
don't think so and so i think
like a bubble gum cigarette
what you know um what about like a
pompadour wig for halloween
just like a one time one seasonal
thing you're not gonna make that much
money you'll make like four dollars
and then gavin will not be happy the
best idea i've heard is a hair product
yes like a pomade or something a conan
pomade yeah and that i mean but then
again i think i've been sticking with
this hairstyle that i came up with like
in the 80s just because i realized my
hair could do it and that's the only
reason i did it no one's ever emulated
it no one's ever said
you know jennifer aniston people wanted
the rachel you know george clooney had
that caesar do or whatever he had on er
and everybody wanted it no one i've been
sticking with this for like 35 years
not one person has ever said get me some
of that no one's ever gone to a barber
and said give me a conan yeah no one not
one person so why is anyone gonna buy
the conan pomade they're not
there's not one product i can think of
and i implore my listeners if you think
there's a product that lines up with me
yeah
pitch it
maybe i'll even cut you in but i want it
to be something realistic not a joke
like
toilet seat you know no
okay
why are you guys laughing furniture
no no one wants to sit like what would
the furniture be i don't know i was
thinking about lenny kravitz he just did
a thing with i think creighton barrel
he's lenny kravitz so cool he's cool he
is so cool i'll buy anything lenny
kravitz tells me to buy yeah you know
okay well
sorry a little extreme i love lenny crap
yeah lenny kravitz smoke detector yeah
that's great i want the i want the
carbon monoxide detector lenny kravitz
designed no i want one that's made
that's uh approved you know by osha oh
blaise says sunscreen
oh sunscreen has been pitched but again
i don't think anybody wants
to look like me i'm freckled there's a
lot of people who have your complexion
who are like what is the best sun
protection and then if they see your
face on a bottle they'll be like that
must be real good stuff yeah because
he's still alive
still alive
i don't know we've got to crack this
because i do want a product that's just
selling out on shelves
and the money's just rolling in and i'm
going to get a bentley yeah and i'm
going to wear a yachting cap and just be
an incredible douchebag just drive
around and be like the money's just
pouring in from the sunscreen the pomade
and the
the conan's say jose
and i want to be really obnoxious about
it just constantly be dropping huh you
have no idea how much money's coming in
from that state and guess what it
doesn't even prevent cancer
oh no
we did something so uh
it just doesn't even function properly
you're saying this publicly well i
shouldn't i forgot that this was a
podcast oh okay i thought we were just
talking in a car sometimes i forget
listen if i do come out
with uh sunscreen i do promise it'll
provide some
protection wow you're really selling it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cancer uh the
numbers the spf may be inaccurate but by
the time they track that down i'll be
out of the country okay
i'll say it's a 50 when it's like a 15.
you know
wow but it'll smell like coconut okay
thank you to all our reviewers today and
if you'd like to leave us a review
please go to apple podcast and rate and
review 5 stars we might just read your
view on the air